today marks one year since the first
dose of a Kobe vaccine was administered
in the U.S more than 200 million
Americans are now fully vaccinated and
more than three quarters of the eligible
population received at least one dose
however the latest CBS News poll finds
nearly one-third of people who are
vaccinated have no plans of getting a
booster shot in spite of evidence that
regular vaccinations are not enough to
protect against the Omicron variant CDC
director Dr Rachelle wolinski is here
joining us right now now as we mentioned
three out of 10 people who got the first
two shots say they won't get the booster
Dr fauci says getting the booster shots
give you optimal protection are we just
redefining what it means to be fully
vaccinated you know what we know is that
the more mutations a variant has the
more immune protection that you need and
so now we're facing the Omicron variant
here in the United States we have new
data out of the CDC just this morning
that has demonstrated that about three
percent of our uh very of our disease
here in the United States is from
Omicron 13 here in New York in New York
and so really we want to bolster our
immune protection to fight against this
variant that has a lot of mutations and
so yes we would really like people to
get doubly vaccinated and then get their
booster when they're eligible for their
booster are we setting people up for a
conversation down the line where we say
look every year you need your covet
booster you know we don't know that yet
we have um you know a lot of Sciences
evolving now a lot of uh information
that we're getting about how well the
boosters are working against the Delta
variant and then more data that's
emerging on how well our boosters are
working against the Omicron vary but we
have a lot of different vaccines where
you get two shots and then a boost and
then you're done and so what we don't
know is how long that protection is
going to last over time well earlier we
were talking to Albert borla who I know
you know from Pfizer who was talking
about the new pill what's your take on
the pill and are you concerned that
people will think well I'm not going to
get the vaccine anyway I'll just if I
get the symptoms I'll just run and take
the pills yeah the first and foremost we
need to get people to prevent disease
that's really really
get your vaccine get your booster take
all of those prevention measures but if
you were to get sick with covid then you
know we now have a new tool in our
armamentarium and that's terrific so
should this tool move through the FDA
through authorization the really
important thing here is that you have to
test quickly because you really need to
give it within a pretty narrow window of
symptoms and so if you get because not
everybody gets symptoms though Rochelle
that's the problem and if you don't get
symptoms then you're not really at risk
of severe disease or death so if you
start to get those symptoms then you
really need to test quickly and go
consult with your physician or provider
so that you can get this so if you don't
have the symptoms you don't have to if
even if you get diagnosed if you don't
have the symptoms don't worry about
disease don't worry about something
really serious happening to you well
then I would actually really look and
see whether you're at high risk of
disease whether you're an older
population have a lot of comorbidities
and at risk of progressing to more
serious disease now not all scientists
agree that young or healthy people
should get booster shots and I have
friends and family that say to me well
well Nate I'm young I'm healthy I'm as
strong as an ox and my immune system is
great so why are you telling me I need
something if I'm good right now you know
again it goes back to the more mutations
the variant has the more immune
protection that you need from it so
we're really encouraging everybody who's
eligible 16 17 year olds just became
eligible last week my 17 year old got
his booster over the weekend and we're
really trying to encourage people to get
that boost to bolster their protection
so that they're ready should they
encounter the Omicron variant I'm really
hungry I think a lot of Americans are
really hungry for some sort of a a
conversation about when we start living
with this virus as opposed to being in a
kind of crisis mode where we're changing
the rules and we don't know if we can
plan getting ready for the next thing
yeah getting ready for the next thing
from a from a public health scientific
perspective where when do we shift into
recovery mode and out of crisis mode
um we all want to get there we're not
where we want to be right now but what
I'll say is we have 1100 under deaths
every day still and we can't be Cavalier
about the fact that we're losing so many
lives from this right now those are
directly related related to covet
shouldn't the messaging be though
Rochelle as we sit here there because if
we're going into year two people think
we're waiting for you to sound the Trump
and say it's all clear we're not really
going to get an all clear are we we just
have to face the fact that we're going
to have to live with this true I think
that that's probably too true but what I
would say is we have a lot of control
and power to do that as we come together
as we get vaccinated as we do those
prevention things that work to protect
one another and ourselves and our family
we can bring down the amount of disease
in this country and get much faster to
that place can I just say I'm so glad
you're here at the table that you
actually have legs you're six feet tall
we're so used to seeing you from there
yeah we're so used to seeing you from
here up it's so great to have you in
studio yeah she's six feet tall
thank you very much